friends was just a hand clapping theme
song and six random hot people
each other or that's not true five
random hot people and David Schwimmer's
droopy dog sadness that disguises itself
as actual stage presence and it inspired
a whole generation of bland hot people
sitcoms none of which had a fun
hand clapping theme song which is why
friends is considered a classic but it's
not a classic sign photos are classic
the simpsons is the classic friends is
remembered more for its haircuts than
its punchlines and this as memorable as
a tinder date where you didn't even get
to make out and had to pay for your half
of the meal beards are disgusting snack
food traps hmm honey mustard pringles
and any man that has one is just too
insecure to show you his real face I'm
not a real man but lord knows my face is
doing a decent impression of one my face
says I'll start a bar fight to defend a
woman's honor but the rest of me says
confrontation makes me feel very
nauseous
[Music]
the unrealistic expectations your
parents put on you and your inability to
fulfill them is what ruined your
childhood why can't you play sports why
did you get a 1060 on your SATs we paid
for a tutor George Lucas gave you a
happy-go-lucky minstrel Gungan and
called Darth Vader Annie that's it and
you know what he did with the money he
made selling Star Wars to Disney he gave
all 4.6 billion of it to inner-city
school programs so he's actively
enriching childhoods what have you done
besides complain about George Lucas yeah
Mesa thought so